we have a saying in asgard  where there are wolf's ears wolves teeth  and ear  it's a trap  he's lying just playing games at me for  a sec loki  my ears are sharp too  here's the deal fugitive variant's been  killing our minutemen we haven't been  able to find them  so let's bring in an expert that's me  the criminal could be anywhere anytime  [Applause]  you got to be careful anything we do can  impact the course of history you get  that  okay  the timekeepers are monitoring every  aspect of this case  trusting this man is not a good idea  no one bad is ever truly bad  and no one good is ever truly good  this isn't about you right  [Music]  okay  i believe stupidly  you can be whatever you want to be even  someone good  by the way i should have an equal amount  of security this is insulting you just  can't help yourself  you